what's up youtubes welcome to my channel
Richard on data my name is Richard and
this is the channel where we talk about
all things data related so I want to
talk to you guys today about what a data
scientist actually is because it's a
very amorphous and nebulous term there's
not generally a universally agreed-upon
definition of it and honestly if you
apply to about twelve different jobs
you're probably gonna see fifteen
different job descriptions for it so the
data scientist has been called the
sexiest job of the 21st century and
there's no question that it's one of the
hottest jobs on the market right now
it's also incredibly well-paid a recent
study that was done on this found that
somebody fresh out of school starting in
a data science job is looking at a
median salary of about 95 thousand
dollars a year and then similarly once
you work your way up and start getting
some years experience you start looking
at somewhere around 128 thousand dollars
a year as an average salary now granted
these are just averages obviously these
numbers are gonna be a little higher if
you're in an area with a higher cost of
living but one way or the other you're
gonna be making a pretty good living if
you're a data scientist but what exactly
are the skills required to be a data
scientist well I hate to break it to you
guys but in order to have any chance of
being a data scientist you need to know
our Python Julia sequel skaila Java C C
sharp C++ objective-c and Fortran you
also need to know several business
intelligence technologies so something
like power bi something like tableau you
need to know a lot of Big Data
technology so Hadoop spark MapReduce
also you need to be incredibly well
educated with at least a PhD and you
need to know backwards and forwards
statistics machine learning deep
learning and linear algebra wrong
that's so completely wrong so honestly
you're gonna see some jobs out there the
have these giant lists of requirements
like that but even in those jobs I would
wager a guess the majority of people are
not using those technologies at least
every single one of them every single
day and it's really more of a red flag
that
he doesn't really know what they're
doing from a data standpoint and they're
looking from summer for some magical
outsider to come in and fix all their
data problems so it's really a red flag
that company doesn't really know what
they're doing so before I get into the
core skills that a data scientist has
just a little bit about me so I've been
a data scientist for about five years
now and an hour programmer for about
eight years that's been through a
variety of small companies and large
companies in industry as well as in
academia and through my experience this
is typically the skills that a data
scientist is gonna have to focus on from
day to day now keep in mind I also live
in the Midwest region of the US so if
you're in Silicon Valley or the Bay Area
generally you may have a slightly
different experience because you might
be expected to be on the cutting edge of
data science every day but for your
average Joe run-of-the-mill person just
looking to sharpen their skills and
become a data scientist I think
generally this is gonna be the case so
data science is an incredibly
multidisciplinary field so as a result a
data scientist is often gonna feel a lot
more like a jack-of-all-trades as
opposed to a master of none sort of
thing so it's often helpful to think
about a Venn diagram like this to
summarize the core skills that a data
scientist needs to know and is going to
use every single day so those skill sets
are domain expertise statistics
programming capabilities and
communication and granted there are a
lot of variants on this Venn diagram and
you'll probably see different ones
floating around there out there but to
me this is the most accurate framework
for thinking through what a data
scientist really is so if we start over
here with domain knowledge so that's
basically your understanding of the
physical domain in which the data are
actually generated so let's take
healthcare for example so in healthcare
you typically work with like outpatient
clinics inpatient hospitals and they
have some kind of electronic medical
record or electronic healthcare records
system where your data actually live in
now there's a business process on the
back end which actually generates that
data and really understanding what that
business process looks like is going to
cause you to ask
fundamental questions and really guide
your creative problem-solving process
it's also important to be able to speak
the same language as your stakeholders
as well and what I mean by that is
typically you're going to be working
with people who aren't data people
they're not data scientists they've
never worked with a programming language
in their life but you're trying to give
them some kind of business insight so
it's often easy if you don't know the
domain very well to find something that
you think is really exciting you go to
share it with them and then they just
don't care because that's not the world
that they live in so for that reason
understanding that actual domain is very
very important
unfortunately it's difficult for me to
help you guys out with domain knowledge
because I've only worked with healthcare
and pharma and a couple little ones here
and there myself so I don't know all of
them in and out having said that it's
generally been my experience that once
you start immersing yourself in the
domain you end up getting pretty
acquainted with it after about 6 to 12
months after the 12 month mark or so you
start really being able to sit down have
really solid business development
related conversations now moving over to
the next one we have statistics so
statistics to me is really the science
behind data science now if you had the
other three skills but you're lacking in
statistics
you're probably dabbling in what I like
to call betas pseudoscience
so dates the distance is really about
providing some intuition and some
mathematical backbone behind what you're
doing and you can loosely couple that
skill set together with things like
mathematics linear algebra machine
learning but broadly speaking that skill
set consists of things like knowing what
statistical tests are appropriate for
your problem having some sound
foundation for claims that you may be
making making appropriate conclusions
and then knowing things like a Cox model
linear regression logistic regression
general things like that and now I
should also point out some people think
a data scientist is just a rebranded
statistician and to a certain extent I
do understand that point the term data
scientist is a pretty recent creation
and statistician is something that's
been around for several decades but to
me
you think of that overall skillset as a
statistician to me that really
overemphasizes this part and yeah
obviously it's very important but it's
only one part of this whole
comprehensive framework where all four
parts are incredibly important moving on
to the next item on the list we have
programming capabilities so in the data
science world your core programming
languages are typically R and Python now
in this video I'm not going to get into
which of those two is better or if you
know neither of them which one should
you learn but really the important point
that I want to stress is that working in
a programming language is absolutely
critical and the reason for that is
generally as a data scientist you're
going to be working with other people
now that could be like I said before
people who don't speak the same language
as you as far as a domain but oftentimes
it's going to be other analysts and
other data scientists so being able to
share your work and having that work be
something that's reproducible is going
to be critically important the beauty of
working with a programming language is
also that you have a reproducible paper
trail so you're gonna start from your
raw data and then as you work from your
raw data into some kind of deliverable
that deliverable could be something like
a model it could be a report it could be
a visualization it could be an app but
that code basically shows exactly how
you got from point A to point B that's
really how you show your work similarly
having a reproducible programming
language enables you to do one
functionality and then maybe you're
going to repeat that functionality
multiple times so you have to do it
again for a separate project or for a
separate analysis but because you've
already created that functionality you
can reuse it on your later work so it
ends up saving you a ton of time there's
also a joke in data science that often
times 80% of your time is spent cleaning
data and your other 20% of your time to
spend complaining about cleaning data
and I can tell you there's definitely a
modest element of truth to that but that
data cleaning I can't stress enough that
part's gonna happen in the programming
language that you're working with and
then maybe you get to do something
exciting like building the model or
building a rapport but that part should
also take place inside of that same
Grahame language so moving to the last
item on this list we have communication
skills now that's pretty broad and
there's a lot to unpack behind that one
but if we think about the core
deliverables which you may be working on
as a data scientist let's say it's a
report well you need to be able to put
together a well-written report is it
understandable do you have good language
skills so things like that if it's a
visualization there are actually what's
called tough days graphical principles
for best design of a visualization and
that makes your visualization easy to
read understandable and all that jazz
and similarly if you have an app and
that's your deliverable there are best
overall design principles which you
should be able to to use and now
similarly to you're probably going to be
working in a multidisciplinary
environment so you may have to actually
get along with other data scientists and
write code with them and communicate
with them on the day to day you need to
solve your problem together with your
client and with your stakeholder and
similarly you're gonna have to work
probably in your own company with things
like product owners product managers
generally people who are there to help
you but they don't have the same
background or the same skill set that
you have
so the overall communication skills of
being able to compartmentalize the
technical aspects and the data side of
things and speak the same language as
other people from different backgrounds
that's gonna be something you need to do
on the day-to-day so putting it all
together once you have all four of these
skills you've got signs specifically
data signs and now obviously the
overwhelming majority of people they're
gonna be really good at one or two of
these things and they're really gonna
struggle at one or two of these other
things and that's absolutely okay it's
really important to be able to identify
where you're actually struggling and
then making improvements at it but
really understanding how all four these
things fits together and then actually
being able to work on them and get
better
that's really the course being a good
day of scientist it's worth pointing out
though that the term data science can be
a little bit misleading in fact
sometimes I like to call it data art
rather than data science because it's
actually
tremendously creative field and often
you're not going to be a task taker or a
programmer but you're going to be a
creative problem solver that as a client
could come up to you and say that they
want X but it is kind of your job to
nudge them a little bit and point out
that a solution Y could be offered so
maybe you end up delivering them some
combination of X and y or you end up
delivering them just Y after you explain
why that's better but often that
creative aspect of it and then making
them believe in the first place that Y
is their idea and it's the best solution
so that creative aspect is often
completely where your value is gonna
come from when you work in data science
thanks so much for watching this video
if you enjoyed this video
smash the like button and also hit the
subscribe button it's my plan to use
this channel to upload all kinds of
educational content to help you guys
either become a data scientist for the
first time ever or sharpen the skills
that you already have developed so until
next time richer on data